thanksgiving isn't just about the turkey
the drinks are equally as important so
today we say cheers to whiskey joining
us is ebony west who will show us how to
make a delicious cocktail using
screwball peanut butter whiskey thank
you
how are you today good um this smells so
good i'm really excited about it and
there's whipped cream so i'm happy it's
a win-win it's an easy way to start your
uh holiday and you want to get a little
kicked up right so today we're going to
be making our screwed up irish coffee
and what makes it that there's nothing
irish involved so we're going to be
doing a hundred percent american whiskey
with what his screwball is i'm gonna
have you pour an ounce and a half give
me a four count one one thousand two one
thousand three one thousand
let's keep it going and for it all right
now you wanna throw a little bit of that
coffee in there because you know these
thanksgiving holidays are going to go
it's going to be a long one is this
acceptable to drink in the morning
because it has coffee in it best way to
start your day we call it a morning
screw but we're going to talk about that
later
bit of whipped cream um going for it
we're doing it okay
look at that
and we're done i am a bartender you are
a bartender i feel like you have a
part-time job i don't know how you do it
all thank you we can we can make a good
team right are you gonna give it a try
yeah let's give it a try but you you
have this one i'll have this one we're
gonna do a little cheers oh it's so
festive it's gonna get all over our face
isn't it um
look it's on my lip it's okay
this is so delicious and this could
really pair well with anything and can
you drink this just say on the rocks if
you want or what's the best way to drink
it there is no right way to drink
screwball you can have it with anything
it can be on the rocks it can be
straight even better right now with the
holidays hot chocolate apple cider
eat amazing exactly i heard you in the
background because you are speaking our
language here and it comes in the mini
bottles right it does come in multiple
sizes we have five sizes actually we
have leader a 750 um a 375 is the one
that you see right here at 200 and this
is our small version right here so you
know if you're stressed out about being
with your family for a few days you can
just throw those in your purse and
they'll never know it's definitely going
to get awkward
and with with family screwball has a
culture based on family and it's really
important to us we just want to
acknowledge one of the people in las
vegas a family that acknowledged us very
early when we first started and that
would be the lee family
we give sincere condolences to them
because they were with us from day one
and we really appreciate it yeah they're
always been huge supporters and a true
loss to our community but thank you for
mentioning that and definitely support
screwball peanut butter whiskey and you
can't go wrong has peanut butter in it
right yes we're all 50 steaks can get us
anywhere all right thanks have any
cheers to that